what do you think about westworld
two episodes in so i can tell you guys
so far yeah
i'm just guessing what's going to happen
next it seems like
bad things are going to happen with the
robots uprising alert
so i i have no i have not i mean you
know i vaguely remember a movie existing
so i assume it's it's related to that
but that was more my time than your time
charles that's right because you're much
older than i i think the important thing
here is that
uh it's narrative right it's all about
telling a story that's the whole driving
thing
but the idea that they would give these
reveries that they would make
they would make them remember remember
the awful things that happened that
happened
who could possibly think that was good i
mean i don't know i've only seen the
first two episodes or maybe the third
one i think i've only seen you know what
it was you know what the problem is
that the robots were actually designed
by hannibal lecter that's true
so like what do you think is going to
happen it's a bad thing
it's clear that things are happening and
characters are being introduced and we
don't yet know anything
but still i was just struck by how it's
all driven by narrative and story and
there's all these implied things like
programming hap the programming
interface is talking to them about
what's going on in their heads
which is both i mean artistically it's
probably useful to film it that way but
think about how it would work in real
life that just seems very crazy but
there was
we saw in the second episode there's a
screen you could see things they were
wearing like
in the world it was quite interesting
just kind of ask this question
so far i mean i assume it veers often to
never never land at some point
but uh we can't answer that question i'm
also a fan of a guy named alex garland
he's a director of ex machina and
he is the first i wonder if kubrick was
like this actually
is he like studies
what would it take to program in ai
systems like he's he's curious enough to
go into that direction
on the west wall side i felt there was
more emphasis on the narratives than
like actually
asking like computer science questions
yeah like how would you
build this how would you uh and how
would you debug it i still think
to me that's the key issue they were
terrible debuggers
yeah and well they said specifically so
we make a change and we put it out in
the world and that's bad because
something terrible could happen like
if you're putting things out in the
world and you're not sure whether
something terrible is going to happen
you're probably
your process is probably i just feel
like there should have been someone
whose sole job it was to walk around and
poke his head in and say
what could possibly go wrong just over
and over again i would have loved if
there was an
and i did watch a lot more and i'm not
giving anything away i would have loved
it if there was like an episode where
like
like the new intern is like debugging a
new model or something and like it just
keeps failing and
they're like all right and then it's
more turns into like a
episode of silicon valley or something
like that yes versus like
all this ominous ai systems that are
constantly like threatening
the the fabric of this world that's been
created yeah yeah and you know the other
the this reminds me of something that so
i agree with that that actually be very
cool at least well for
the small percentage of people who care
about debugging systems but the other
thing is
debugging the series it falls into think
of the sequels fear of the devotion oh
my gosh
and anyway so a nightmare show it's a
horror movie
i think that's where we lose people by
the way early on is the people who
either decide
either figure out debugging or think
debugging is terrible this is where we
lose people in computer science
this is part of the struggle versus
suffering right you you get through it
and you kind of get the skills of it or
you're just like this is dumb and it's a
dumb way to do anything and
i think that's when we lose people but
um i
well i'll leave it at that but i think
that i think that that there's something
really really neat about framing it that
way but what i
don't like about all of these pro all of
these things and i love dex mocking it
by the way i thought the
ending was very depressing um
one of the things i have to talk to al
uh alex about
he says that the thing that nobody
noticed he put in
is uh the at the end spoiler alert
the the robot turns and looks at the
camera
and smiles right briefly and to him
he thought that his definition of
passing
the touring the general version of the
touring test or the consciousness test
is smiling for no one oh
like like not
oh you know it's it's like the chinese
room kind of experiment it's not always
trying to act for others
right but just on your own being able to
have a relationship
with the actual experience and just like
take it in
i don't know he said like nobody noticed
i mean the magic of it i had this vague
feeling that i
remember the smile but now you now you
just put the memory in my head so
probably not but i do think that that's
interesting although by looking at the
camera
you are smiling for the audience right
you're breaking the fourth wall it seems
i mean well that's a that's a limitation
in the medium but i i like that idea but
here's the problem i have with all of
those movies
all of them um is that but i know why
it's this way and i enjoy those movies
um and westworld is uh it sets up the
problem of ai
as succeeding and then having something
we cannot control
but it's that's not the bad part of ai
the bad part of ai is the stuff we're
living through now right it's the
using the data to make decisions that
are terrible it's not the intelligence
that's going to go out there and surpass
us and
you know take over the world or you know
lock us into a room to starve to death
slowly over multiple days it's instead
the the tools that we're building that
are allowing
us to make the terrible decisions we
would have less efficiently made before
right
you know computers are very good at
making us more efficient including being
more efficient at doing terrible things
and
and that's the part of the ai we have to
worry about it's not the
you know true intelligence that we're
going to build sometime in the future
probably
long after we're around um but you know
i i i just i think that whole framing of
it sort of misses
the point even though it is inspiring
and i was inspired by those ideas right
that i got into this in part because i
wanted to build something like that
philosophical questions were interesting
to me but but you know that's not where
the terror comes from the terror comes
from the every day
and you can construct situations in the
subtlety of the interaction between ai
and the human
like with the with social networks all
the stuff you're doing with uh
interactive artificial intelligence but
you know i i feel like
cal 9000 came a little bit closer to
that when it's
in 2001 space odyssey because it felt
like
uh a personal assistant you know it felt
like closer to the ai systems we have
today and and the
and the real things we might actually
encounter which is
over relying uh on in some
fundamental way on our like dumb
assistance
or on social networks like over
offloading too much of us
onto uh you know onto
things that require internet and power
and so on
and thereby becoming powerless as a
stand-alone entity and then when that
thing starts to misbehave
in some subtle way it creates a lot of
problems
and those problems are dramatized when
you're in space because
you don't have a way to walk away well
as the man said
um once you once we started making the
decisions for you it stopped being your
world
right that's the matrix michael in case
you don't i didn't generally i don't
remember
but on the other hand i could say no
because isn't that what we do with
people anyway
you know this kind of the shared
intelligence that is humanity is relying
on other people constantly to i mean we
hyper-specialize right as individuals
we're still generally intelligent we
make our own decisions in a lot of ways
but we leave most of this up to other
people and
that's perfectly fine and by the way
everyone doesn't necessarily
share our goals sometimes they seem to
be quite against us sometimes we
make decisions that others would see as
against our own interests and yet we
somehow manage it
manage to survive i'm not entirely sure
why an ai
would actually make that worse
or even different really
you